here's when we first met Donnie Wahlberg
I got everything that you could ask for
and I'm only 21 years old I mean for a
kid who grew up in Dorchester with
nothing you know with food stamps and no
money in my pocket man that's that's
really something man it goes
[Music]
kids are our peers and not just our fans
and stuff good believe me when they be
kissing all on Donny designed the
clothes wrote some songs and the band's
name New Kids on the Block came from one
of his rap songs they were originally
called men up and back in 1989 before
selfies were a thing Donny would even
help fans take photo sell like the
attentions we did his signature look
became long hair no shirt and some very
memorable dance moves
growing up I had fights all the time
I had incidences all the time but now
I'm a new kid on the rock I'm so famous
and the press has given us this
goody-two-shoes image but we never
claimed to be good we just claimed to be
positive he was with the new kids as
they toured the world Chile Japan even
taking on the Superbowl
Doni always gave his all onstage so much
that during a June concert in 1990 he
fell through a trapdoor on stage and
ended up in the hospital just a few days
later he was back I never changed my
stage performance you know I may look a
few places before I leave Donny's
younger brother mark was one of the
original members of NKOTB but he left
early on this respect the brothers have
always supported each other bonded by
their sometimes tough upbringing my
brother and I I think that's one thing
we both have it's it's a relentless work
ethic and I think we've watched our dad
drive a truck you know to try to support
nine kids in the 1990s the new kids
broke up but thankfully only for a while
in 2008 the band got back together fans
are definitely reacting the right way
yowsa
in the middle of more hit records and
tours Donny became an actor shooting
Blue Bloods between gigs
a tour with the Backstreet Boys brought
all of our boyband dreams to life and
the day the new kids got their star on
the Walk of Fame iceless we wanted it's
a great honor and I think what it
represents for us is you know it's 30
years Donny is now 50 and life is pretty
sweet
especially with Jenny by his side I
adore him I love it so so much I love
him and we work this it's work we love
each other it's fun but we put in the
time
[Music]
[Applause]